[Música]
si fue Alejandro
invitar a dos célebres chefs de la
cocina al huerto de Jacky Mesías es como
soltar ratones en un almacén de quesos
quieren probarlo todo
tomate piña durazno rosado tetilla de
Venus naranja Queen o corazón de res las
variedades de tomates antiguos de Yaqui
son todo un poema
de visita comelona donde su horticultor
el bearnés e iñaki pitarte el Vasco son
dos cocineros respetados por sus pares
su tema La astronomía una gastronomía
más auténtica donde el producto y los
pequeños productores regresan al corazón
de la cocina ver a la persona que lo
hace su entorno sus convicciones el
trabajo realizado para alcanzar la
calidad
no tratas el producto de la misma manera
después cuando llega la canasta ves la
cara del Yaki detrás de ello entonces
respetas aún más el producto
estos grandes chefs enloquecen por las
variedades de tomates antiguos de Yaki
messier porque este pequeño productor
instalado en la bien cultiva desde hace
mucho tiempo el gusto por las las cosas
bien hechas
aquí estamos en mi terreno Por supuesto
donde produzco mis tomates mis plantas
aromáticas las verduras principalmente
porque siempre ha sido mi pasión
Una Pasión por el tomate que empezó hace
40 años con un hilo conductor sin
pesticidas y sobre todo hacerlos crecer
al aire libre en vez de invernaderos
[Música]
así como él así no no no sé si en Brasil
Mírame bien mis colegas quieren tenerlos
rápido apostar por la productividad
se necesita un invernadero pero no es la
calidad al aire libre viven momentos de
frío calor es lo que les da el gusto
miren por favor ves la distancia con
respecto a la cuerda
tiemblenla de nuevo hay que volver a
empezar Pascal siempre se siembra a la
derecha es tal vez el secreto de los
tomates de yakimisier carácter
autenticidad y mucha paciencia
unos meses más tarde en las cajas del
horticultor asistimos a un festival de
formas y colores tomates antiguos 40
buenas noticias a dónde van esos
almacenes orgánicos en alguien y
principalmente a París
vienen del mismo terreno Así del mismo
terreno
no hago distinción
distensión la gente de la bien tiene
derecho a comer los mismos tomates que
la gente de París
y así empiezan las entregas un
transportador garantizará las entregas
en París
la próxima semana habrá menos sí Jackie
supervisa el mismo el acondicionamiento
tiene que gustar todo
Sí sí
soy obsesivo con mis tomates con toda la
mercancía una exigencia que tiene su
reputación
creo que ser dedicado con las entregas
la presentación todo
lo que me ha permitido trabajar con
París y sin problema
tiene que respirar en París más de 70
restaurantes y aprovisionan donde Jackie
pero también las cocinas del senado y la
asamblea nacional sus tomates han
seducido a los palacios más exigentes
[Música]
aquí
nos reunimos con nits en la cocina de su
restaurante berro potente
ensalada tomate ricota
perro y nueces
este mediodía tuvo la idea vamos a hacer
tomate machacado crudo
quisiera servido con los vecinos que
llegaron y haremos tomate machacado
intensificado
potente
para reemplazar la mayonesa
con su gusto inimitable y sus colores
sorprendentes el tomate llega a las
grandes mesas creo que le estamos dando
de nuevo su Nobleza a todos estos
productos cotidianos que no eran
considerados productos gastronómicos
Ahora cuando se trata de un buen
producto ya sea un tomate un coliflor
caviar un rapé
cuando es bueno es bueno y es
gastronómico pero cuando Jackie no está
en sus terrenos o en la carretera para
hacer entregas a los grandes
restaurantes vende sus verduras en los
mercados tiene sabor a manzana
en estos exhibidores de un pequeño
pueblo de bien se encuentra tal vez los
mejores tomates de Francia
[Música]